Even when they're axed in spectacularly gory
fashion, a fallen star of The Walking Dead
gets to walk away with a major feather in
their cap for being on one of TV's most popular
programs.
Here's a look at what's happened to these
killed-off Walking Dead actors since they
departed the show.
Love him or hate him, Jon Bernthal's Shane
Walsh was a very big deal in The Walking Dead's
earliest seasons.
Shortly after his departure from the show,
Bernthal starred in Martin Scorsese's The
Wolf of Wall Street as Quaalude supplier Brad
Bodnick.
He also landed the leading role in Mob City,
from original Walking Dead showrunner Frank
Darabont and continued to impress in cinematic
action fare like Fury and Baby Driver.
Apart from his Walking Dead role, though,
Bernthal is perhaps best known for his turn
as Frank Castle in Marvel's The Punisher for
Netflix.
Sarah Wayne Callies' Lori Grimes was another
divisive but paramount part of The Walking
Dead's initial run.
Though she was initially hesitant to take
on another TV role after The Walking Dead,
she landed a leading role in USA Network's
alien invasion series Colony, which lasted
for three seasons.
Soon after, she also reprised her most noteworthy
pre-Dead role in Fox's Prison Break revival.
While most of The Walking Dead's deathbound
cast members get a call from the showrunners
to let them know their characters are being
killed off, it was Jeffrey DeMunn who did
the dialing about Dale's fate.
The actor had a long working relationship
with Frank Darabont, and said he was "furious"
about how Darabont had been "pushed out of
the show" after its inaugural season, so he
quit.
It didn't take long for DeMunn to reconnect
with Darabont.
DeMunn starred as police chief Hal Morrison
in Darabont's short-lived noir series Mob
City.
He's branched out into other TV projects since
then, as well.
After enjoying guest roles on several popular
series, DeMunn became a regular on Showtime's
Billions as the central character's father,
Chuck Rhoades, Sr.
Laurie Holden was also one of The Walking
Dead's initial cast members who had a prior
working relationship with Darabont on The
Mist.
But the death of Andrea wasn't as instantaneous
as Dale's.
In fact, she became an important factor in
season 3's war with the Governor, until she
faced an especially gnarly demise at the hands
of his reawakened henchman.
Since her Walking Dead departure, Holden enjoyed
a recurring role on FX's The Americans as
Renee, the new wife of the series' central
FBI agent who, spoilers, may or may not have
actually been a Russian spy.
She also has a recurring role on Fox's legal
drama Proven Innocent.
Unlike most of the earliest characters in
The Walking Dead, Merle Dixon did not first
come from the comics and was instead an original
creation of the show.
Actor Michael Rooker had never struggled to
secure work before, but things really started
to take off after The Walking Dead.
In fact, he may even be better known for his
work in the MCU as Guardians of the Galaxy's
Yondu than Merle.
He's also since starred in films like The
Belko Experiment and HBO's third season of
True Detective.
As The Walking Dead's first major antagonist,
the Governor brought a lot of shocking moments
to the screen.
Since he left The Walking Dead, David Morrissey
has continued to impress on the small screen,
starting with a regular role as Tobias Shepherd
on the second season of sci-fi series Extant.
Interestingly enough, that allowed him to
work with Jeffrey Dean Morgan, who would later
become The Walking Dead's mega-villain Negan.
Before he joined the rest of the survivors
as Tyreese Williams, Chad L. Coleman was already
known for his performance as Dennis "Cutty"
Wise on HBO's The Wire.
Since his time on Dead came to a heartbreaking
end, Coleman has continued to amass impressive
TV credits.
In addition to enjoying recurring roles on
several popular TV shows, Coleman joined the
cast of The Expanse as Col. Fred Johnson,
who becomes known as "The Butcher of Anderson
Station" for his ruthless attack on a group
of insurgents.
Coleman also appears as the alien Klyden on
FOX's The Orville.
Poor Bob.
When the survivors sought refuge at Terminus,
it was Bob who was made to pay for that mistake
more than anyone else.
He was forced to give a pound of flesh, several
pounds, actually, to satisfy the hunger of
the crazy cannibals who had tricked the group,
but he turned out to be "tainted meat."
In addition to a role on HBO's The Deuce,
actor Lawrence Gilliard Jr., another Wire
alum, also earned a recurring role in USA
Network's final season of Graceland.
If you don't get a chill thinking back on
Gareth's behavior in The Walking Dead's fourth
and fifth seasons, you might be as inhumane
as he was.
Since his character's brutal on-screen execution,
Andrew J. West has made some interesting career
moves.
First, he continued in the vein of villainy
as Damon on Freeform's short-lived horror
series Dead of Summer, but then he showed
everyone that he could totally play the good
guy by becoming the adult version of Henry
Mills in ABC's final season of Once Upon a
Time.
As divisive as Deanna was for some fans of
The Walking Dead, she eventually wised up
and ceded all her authority in Alexandria
to Rick Grimes.
So, in the end, she definitely did not deserve
what was coming to her in season 6, and her
death was pretty sad.
Things have been going just swimmingly for
Tovah Feldshuh in real life, though.
The actress has since earned several recurring
roles on new shows, including playing the
President of the United States on CBS' Salvation
and guest-starring as Rachel Bloom's overbearing
mother on The CW's Crazy Ex-Girlfriend.
After his beloved character Glenn was killed
off in the premiere of season 7, Steven Yeun
made some big moves to capitalize on his small
screen fame.
First, he appeared in a few movies, including
Netflix's Okja, Sorry to Bother You, and the
critically-acclaimed Korean film Burning.
His TV cred is only going to increase, too,
as he stars in an episode of Jordan Peele's
reboot of The Twilight Zone, and he's also
set to perform in another property based on
the comics of Robert Kirkman, the animated
superhero series Invincible.
Glenn might've run out of luck on the show,
but his real-life counterpart is doing just
fine.
Like Glenn, Abraham and his epic mustache
were both grossly mistreated by Negan's batting
practice session at the beginning of season
7.
Actor Michael Cudlitz journeyed back to Alexandria
to jump behind the lens and direct an episode
for season 9 and signed on to do so again
for season 10.
The long-working actor has also had no trouble
getting jobs that put him in front of the
lens, including guest roles in House of Lies
and Young Sheldon, and a regular role as the
Cleary family patriarch in ABC's The Kids
Are Alright.
Jessie was eaten alive by walkers in Season
6 while experiencing the anguish of watching
her son get devoured right in front of her,
because The Walking Dead simply has no cap
on cruelty.
TV fans are most likely to recognize Alexandra
Breckenridge from NBC's hit drama series This
Is Us, which introduced her as Kevin Pearson's
long-time love interest Sophie.
She's also appeared on American Horror Story:
Coven and leads the cast of Netflix's drama
series Virgin River.
A few months before Sasha's final episode
aired, the news dropped that Sonequa Martin-Green
had landed the leading role of Michael Burnham
in CBS' Star Trek: Discovery, which made her
exit from The Walking Dead seem inevitable.
Martin-Green's career shows no signs of slowing,
as Discovery has been renewed for a third
season, and she's been tapped to star in the
sequel to Space Jam.
Last but not least, let's pour one out for
poor Duane Jones.
The kiddo only appeared in the very first
episode of The Walking Dead, but his presence
was pivotal to establishing the mood of the
series.
Since the show, actor Adrian Kali Turner has
continued to work steadily in films and TV,
including appearing in the pilot for Don't
Trust the B—- in Apartment 23 and in Bad
Teacher with Cameron Diaz.
Turner has grown up quite a bit since his
days on The Walking Dead and even recently
shared a photo of himself holding a little
Duane doll for old time's sake.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.